hey i bet you you paid more in taxes
than donald trump did though right
yeah ain't no i mean but i only like i
eat five
only thing i can buy takes you i'm just
about to file taxes but
in life like you haven't filed taxes
once
but you know what like it's okay because
all that feature money you know i gotta
count it i got i gotta
i gotta count it though like i i got my
stuff on tabs like for the last three
years
i just haven't filed a jet you know what
i'm saying you gotta fight that they
gonna crack you for them penalties
yeah i probably i feel like like i said
like i i mean i got hey [ __ ] it the
president i really really had a lot of
music expenses like i'd invested
so much the president's not paying taxes
why should you man
that man paid 750 one thing about music
though everything
is an investment like this juror
investment like this
what what what i what everybody let me
know so
when you say this jewelry is an
investment i feel like
most people would say that artists [ __ ]
up by getting
jewelry yeah you know what i'm saying
like it's a mistake
yeah when you say it's an investment
what do you mean
uh i i see it as like
in in the
the way of that's how you can sell it
you know that's how you can sell it to
uh the the people the irs you know
it is because it can be looked at as an
investor oh i see what you're saying so
like
the irs you could be like this was you
know wardrobe yeah it is
your jewelry expenses yeah that's
[ __ ] great yeah i feel like
it's a crop for a music video yeah you
know what i'm saying but
i feel like a lot of artists it is like
a symbol to them
like jury really like you know what i'm
saying for
because you have a screen yeah yeah like
for screen [ __ ] like druid like is a
a trophy like it's like a trophy ain't
really nothing to
say um this or that it's just like a
trophy like okay i mean
i made it this far man i deserve a
change i deserve some time i want to
shine like i want to shine
i want to shine bright i want to be seen
because i've been slipped on and
people you know saying then throw the
rug up over me
so so long for so many years i'm getting
money
you know i want people to see me it's
kind of like a trophy like a you know
saying type type of death now that makes
sense
i mean yeah i just think some people
just like the way it looks